[Music]
all right as we continue from hanoi
in vietnam well yesterday journalist
jorge ramos and univision staffers
they were detained at the presidential
palace in venezuela
after an interview with venezuelan
dictator nicholas maduro
now apparently maduro didn't like the
questions that were asked and
ended the interview when jorge ramos
showed him
this video of hungary venezuelans eating
out of a garbage truck
after being held for three hours the
group was thankfully released
univision news anchor jorge ramos joins
us now
uh first of all i'm glad you're out uh i
was nervous about what was happening
and we disagree but i don't disagree on
protecting all americans whoever they
are wherever they are and
i said it last night and i mean it i'm
saying it to you personally
and and i want to thank you personally
sean i know that we have many
differences on immigration and put those
differences aside
because when when i needed that support
the most
i heard that you were talking about us
in venezuela and that was incredibly
important
so from the bottom of my heart thank you
so much sean thanks so much to fox news
because uh and on those moments when you
are detained in a dictatorship
when there's no one to help you and you
see a tweet
or you see a report from fox news or
from an american media
you know that you're not alone and we
felt that we were not alone
so much gracias yeah listen
uh will be uh i'm not great with my i
studied in school for three years but
it's not great jorge
um let's tell everybody what happened
because they took your tapes
by the way those are real videos of real
venezuelans it should be one of the
richest countries
in the entire world that are eating out
of garbage trucks
and that is widespread and i applaud you
for calling attention to the suffering
of human beings this isn't politics to
me
it is terrible what's happening right
now in in venezuela there's a
humanitarian crisis
the minimum wage sean is five dollars
not five dollars an hour
or five dollars a day five dollars a
month
that's the minimum wage so that's why
there's so much hunger we i had the
interview with nicolas maduro it lasted
about 17 minutes i think it was a strong
interview it was
it was all right but then i show him the
kids that you just
showed um on a garbage truck and
and he just couldn't stand it he stood
up he tried to cover
um the the image so the cameras wouldn't
be able to see it
and then i told him uh mr maduro i
didn't call him president i
called him mr maduro what are you doing
why don't you answer the questions
what you are doing is what dictators do
and then and then he left one of his
ministers came back
they confiscated uh four cameras sean
they took our tape cards where we
actually
store the the interviews and then they
detain us for two
hours they took away uh our cell phones
and at this point at this point we don't
have the cameras
we don't have the interview and they
gave my
self back although all the cell phones
from my colleagues
they're still in venezuela you know
we're having a debate in this country
and i i you
everyone knows we have a well-documented
disagreement on
immigration and border security and
american sovereignty and american law
we'll put that aside
but you know i look at a country like
venezuela
all the grandiose promises we'll take
care of everything we'll do everything
government socialism
it fails and i'm just curious
as you see this these arguments being
made in our country
uh about 70 percent tax rates marginal
rates
uh guaranteed education health care jobs
security
everything college i'm wondering if you
see the dangers as i do how socialism
does
almost universally lead to poverty and
false promises
what i saw in venezuela is that the 20
year old revolution it started with
chavez in 1999
has failed completely you have more than
3 million venezuelans
live in the country inflation is 1
million percent
if they pay one bolivar today it will be
a million believers
in in a year from now and people are
dying i went to a hospital hospital
vargas
and then one woman she has lost a family
member and you know why
because they didn't have 30 dollars to
pay for antibiotics so the experiment
in venezuela has failed completely and
you know something i i really appreciate
the
the freedom and the liberties that we
have here in the united states you know
we know that that i have my differences
with with president trump but this is
the difference
you can criticize the president of the
united states and i can go home and
nothing happens to me
sean but if i criticize the dictator of
venezuela
they confiscate my cameras they take
my interviews they detain me and then
they expel me from the country
those are two big big differences last
thing i'll add this is a political point
that i'll make you know
obama eight years 13 million more
americans on food stamps
8 million more in poverty
millions lost their doctors their plans
they have one option
and everybody paid more those are the
false promises i think of socialism and
the danger
and under donald trump look at this
record low unemployment
for americans hispanic americans asian
americans women in the workplace
and i come from very blue-collar roots
i want the forgotten men and women in
this country
and frankly the world to have the
blessings of freedom that we
we take for granted as i can see here in
vietnam a lot of poverty
and i understand your political point
and if you allow me in this case
especially for this interview
i'll concentrate on what i saw in
venezuela and healthcare in venezuela
the socialist healthcare in venezuela is
is
terrible i mean i i saw this woman who
just didn't have enough money for
antibiotics i saw a family
who's 15 year old christian is dying
because they couldn't do blood tests in
the hospital so they took
uh his blood in a tooth and they put it
in a in a glass with eyes and they had
to take it to another place and and the
boy
most likely will die very soon simply
because they don't have enough
medicines so that's what's happening
with the revolution
the venezuelan revolution right now with
nicolas maduro
we may disagree on immigration very
strongly
but we agree on humanitarian issues
and we do the and poverty and what's
happened there
uh i'm glad you're out and next time
we're going to have another fight so
you know but we're going to fight and
first
and let me thank the u.s department um
the state department
and the american embassy in caracas
thanks to them um i'm here today in
miami
i think you should just say i love
donald trump and it'll all be over it's
all good
uh welcome home not today not today sean
thank you so much
all right we're glad you're out thank
you